hey youtubers it's Charlie so hopefully
you guys are having a great weekend so
far d23 is going on right now that's
Disney's version to comic-con where it
has everything from movies stuff to
video games to TV shows so they're
showing off everything and remember they
have Marvel they have Star Wars so
they'll have a couple big presentation
starting tomorrow the rumor is someone
was saying on reddit that they had
actually seen a Captain America civil
war trailer or footage I should say
maybe not a proper trailer but at least
a promo reel that heavily featured
spider-man which was really like the
news to me I mean if you've read comic
books Civil War then you already know
how that plays out that's not quite as
spectacular really the new thing is
spider-man at Marvel Studios in case
they didn't mention it earlier this year
the new actor that's playing spider-man
Tom Holland has already filmed his civil
war scenes and even if the description
of the footage that this mystery person
has seen is bogus
I think the matically there's a lot to
it and that spider-man is featured in
some of the big battles of the movie it
makes sense that if they were gonna put
him in the movie they would put him in
the movie in a big way even if he
weren't in that many scenes so what I'm
gonna do is read this description that
the reddit person posted the description
of the footage take it with a grain of
salt the footage begins with general
Thunderbolt Ross talking about the
Registration Act that's right out of the
comics it then cuts to a military team
rappelling down a building we see a
snowy forest we see someone's arm being
ejected close-ups of Black Widow Hawkeye
Scarlet Witch and war machine fighting
in Wakanda it actually says Wanda but I
think this person just has really shitty
grammar general Ross says you either
sign yourself over or this is your last
stand then Captain America says we won't
stand for this
yeah that's amazing dialogue then
Ironman says then let's fight we see a
skyscraper explode Captain America and
Iron Man fight in a baseball field we
see Bucky hanging out of a helicopter
Black Widow and Falcon fighting we see
black panther fight Captain America
close-ups of crossbones we see a
close-up of someone's legs walking maybe
Baron Zemo just says in parentheses you
think the world can survive says Zemo
let's find out says spider-man is we see
a close-up of spider-man fighting Baron
Zemo vision destroys a helicopter
hawkeye zip-lining between buildings
ant-man punches vision
we see crossbones and Captain America
fight then general Ross says everything
you fought for will come crumbling down
we see Martin Freeman's character
driving a car
iron man shoots Captain America we see
spider-man swinging through buildings in
a blue and red suit it says not black in
parentheses I guess some people thought
that it might be black and red and then
iron man punches Captain America's
shield and it cuts to the Civil War logo
okay so that's like a whole bunch of
jump cutting between scenes and a lot of
stuff mismatched so like Spider Man
might not end up fighting Baron Zemo
that seems a bit strange it seems more
like he would be fighting the Avengers
characters really I think this is kind
of bogus and what I'm taking from it
though is that when they do their
presentation we will see spider-man with
the characters we're within about 10
months of Captain America's Civil War
the movie coming out usually when we get
within that one-year mark like once we
cross that barrier is when we see new
footage but a lot of times it gets
attached to other big Disney movies or
like other big Marvel movies if there is
one I'm guessing the ant-man was just a
little too far out and they have Star
Wars coming so they want to promote Star
Wars more than they want to promote
Captain America Civil War so I think
it'll probably be Star Wars before we
see like a giant big trailer but that's
actually pretty close to me like that's
less than six months meaning that we'll
probably get a proper civil war trailer
sometime during the fall like October or
November so they don't release any
footage at all at d23 tomorrow then what
we'll probably just see is a couple of
new images Spider Man being part of that
Marvel is kind on this cake where they
even don't really need other people's
conventions to release their information
they can do they can just post it out
right there that popular that was kind
of what that phase 3 announcement was
earlier this year like at the beginning
of the year they did a special
presentation just for their Marvel
movies now a lot of stuff hadn't
happened whenever they did that like
they hadn't closed the spider-man deal
they hadn't signed Benedict Cumberbatch
to Doctor Strange yet so it's always
possible that Marvel could do something
like that in the fall the thing is
though is that there is no separate
Marvel presentation at d23 what they do
is it's like a Disney live-action
presentation so it's all the Marvel all
the Star Wars stuff everything
live-action so that includes Johnny Depp
Pirates of the Caribbean that kind of
stuff to d23 is a
little bit different from comic-con and
that it doesn't have a bunch of
different Studios doing presentations
for a couple movies
it just has like one big live-action
presentation and really the star of the
show right now is Star Wars Episode
seven there isn't gonna be a new Star
Wars trailer JJ Abrams already announced
there's no new footage that won't come
like the next big Star Wars trailer
won't come till like October or November
he said the fall but that could be like
early November we did just see some
pictures of black panther the other day
on the set those were unofficial though
that was just like somebody walking near
the set taking pics with a telephoto
lens the takeaway is that black panther
suit without a bunch of CG special
effects looks a lot more like the fabric
of vision suit it looks like that's just
the way they're visualizing vibranium
weave if you haven't seen any of the
animated movies I think that some
animated Avengers movies that feature
Wakanda and black panther his suit
actually kind of looks like spandex but
it's made of vibranium weave it's like
vibranium cloth it's like if you've ever
worn Under Armor it's like it's really
form-fitting really lightweight but it
has all the benefits of vibranium it's
it's almost impenetrable like it's as
strong as Iron Man's armor who else is
wondering now - if Iron Man is gonna
make a vibranium Iron Man suit I feel
like that would be one of the first
things on his mind if you were to broker
a deal with Stark Industries in Wakanda
like I will pay you all the money in the
world if you will give me your vibranium
suddenly everyone flashes back to
Ulysses Klaw where Ultron gave him like
billions and billions of dollars for his
vibranium supply the thing about that
too is is that like all that vibranium
but he took a ton of vibranium from
Ulysses Klaw and every last bit of it
was used to make the vision but you have
to consider that visions entire body
like every last piece of him is made of
vibranium he's not just a regular robot
with a vibranium suit on top let me know
what you guys think though what do you
think about this you know supposed
Captain America footage description I
think it's a little bit bogus usually
reddit is more miss than hit but I do
think that there's truth to the fact
that spider-man will be fighting with
the Avengers characters it just it seems
stupid to not let him do that what's
gonna be happening this weekend is
because there's gonna be a bunch of
Marvel bunch of Star Wars stuff that's
what most of my videos are gonna be
about like I'll do some Star Wars
Episode 7 stuff and then depending on
whatever they announced for Captain
America Civil War in the other Marvel
movies I'll do videos for that stuff
most of that is going down tomorrow
so like most of the news that we get
will be dropping tomorrow morning and
they're not live-streaming the panel so
there's not really any way to watch it
but this isn't quite as big as comic-con
and in terms of them showing off new
footage it kind of gets lumped in with
that other Disney live-action stuff but
get hype there's still like a whole
bunch of awesome stuff happening the
arrow people even just showed off
concept footage of the new arrow cave
let's just say it looks a little bit
more like the Justice League Watchtower
like they're just getting a bunch of
tech upgrades but I'll talk about that
more the next time I do an arrow flash
video this weekend is primarily going to
be Marvel Star Wars I'll tell you what
just for fun I'll do a Marvel giveaway
this weekend if there's no Captain
America Civil War announcement I'll give
away one Amazon gift cards just - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
real simple just like the other
giveaways if they do release Captain
America Civil War footage I'll give away
three gift certificates just because our
brains will be melting a little bit so
while you guys wait for all that stuff
to drop you can click here for my top
ten spider-man costumes from the comics
they've been talking a lot about his
costume in Captain America Civil War and
you can click here to learn all about
Black Panther in the comics learn about
the history of Black Panther thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you